indicate increasing Transmission in
recent week weeks unfortunately we're
now beginning to see Rising severity
Trends as well
some degree of increased transmission
was expected
we are once again reminded that we need
to maintain a vaccine plus approach with
a layering of precautions to help lower
infection rates protect vulnerable
populations and dampen the impact on our
health system
up to date the vaccination continues to
be the strong core of this strategy
experts across Canada and worldwide
continuously monitor safety and
Effectiveness data and adapt to vaccine
recommendations to provide people with
the best possible protection over time
and as the virus continues to evolve
reassuringly the latest evidence tells
us that getting an mRNA covid-19 vaccine
boosted dose can provide longer lasting
protection and better Effectiveness even
if you have been previously infected
this is why Canada's chief medical
officers of Health are urging people to
keep up to date with all recommended
doses of covid-19 vaccines including
booster doses
because the omicon variant is immune
evasive two doses of the covid-19
vaccines offer less protection against
this variant than previous variants the
good news is that boosters can help
increase antibody levels
that weighing over time after the second
dose
although vaccine Effectiveness against
infection decreases over time evidence
shows that two doses of mRNA vaccines
generally maintain good Effectiveness
against severe outcomes across variants
and a booster further increases vaccine
Effectiveness to over 90 percent against
severe outcomes
um
Bianca Levy Cassity the vaccine
controllers
against infections
90 against severe outcomes the national
advisory committee on immunization has
updated guidance on the use of first
booster doses which they strongly
recommend for adults age 18 years of or
older and Adolescence aged 12 to 17
years who are at higher risk of severe
outcomes or exposure
in addition Massey recommends a first
boost of those may now be offered to
anyone aged 12 years or older in the
context of heightened epidemiological
risk
given our immune system is less able to
maintain robust protection as we age I
would especially urge all people age 50
years or older to get booster doses as
recommended for the first boost of those
at least six months after the primary
series
at this time Massey recommends that
second booster doses be rapidly deployed
and prioritized for those who are
expected to benefit the most
namely residents of long-term care homes
or other congregate living settings for
seniors as well as seniors age 80 years
or older living in the community
Nasi also recommends that jurisdictions
may choose to offer a second covid-19
boost of those to adults 70 to 79 years
of age living in the community
there is still a lot we can do to dampen
down the current trajectory we know that
using personal protective measures like
masking helps reduce transmission
likewise getting a boost of those
doesn't just protect you against severe
illness it also protect provides a level
of protection against infection which in
turn helps to reduce transmission
the more of us getting up to date with
our covid-19 vaccines with booster doses
the greater the effect to lessen the
overall impact of the wave which can
help protect vulnerable populations and
preserve Health Care capacity for
everyone
so getting a boost of those matters and
I urge every eligible person person
hasn't yet updated the vaccinations to
check in with your health provider or
local public health authority to see
what additional doses you're eligible
for
is
19 vaccines now
however with disease activities very
high and still rising in many
communities it's important to use other
precautions like masking improving
ventilation or opting for outdoor
settings and staying home if we have
symptoms or have tested positive
as Ramadan continues and with Passover
Easter and other long weekend
celebrations and opportunities to gather
before us let's keep doing our best to
protect each other
while uncertainties remain we also need
to be prepared for Resurgence of
covid-19 in the fall and winter and the
potential need for additional covid-19
boosters at that time
thank you merci magnet
will not start with the questions if you
have a question please raise your
hands
husband Canadian press
good morning Dr Tam
we've been you've spoken in the past
about the need to empower people to be
able to make their own Public Health
decisions
um in the context of restrictions being
lifted we're hearing from people that
they feel that they don't have the tools
to do that that they don't have the
information to know about their local
sort of epidemiological situation and
assess their own risk so what more needs
to be done to help give them the tools
to actually Empower them to make those
personal decisions
yes thank you for that question that's
really important right now though that's
just let me just emphasize all across
Canada doesn't matter where you are it's
very likely that Omicron variant the ba2
sub lineage is spreading quite widely in
your community so it doesn't matter
where you are in Canada right now I
would advise getting that who's the shot
and
masking and improving ventilation
so I think
um that should be helpful to everyone
trying to figure out the risk
assessments we have developed some tools
for personal risk assessment
um depending your own on your own
Medical
or an underlying conditions or Age and
what kind of setting you're entering
into however I think your point is well
taken which is we need to continuously
provide some of the epidemiologic
information that we know about
so I think as the well the number of
tests are continuing to increase right
now I think not unexpectedly because the
curve is going up there's more people
being tested so we can still Trend uh
the the upward rise of that curve even
if we're testing less so still keep
looking at that epidemiologic curve on
the cases and the hospitalization and
the deaths in your community for more
and more local communities are also
communicating their Wastewater signals
for example as a supplementary signal
and you see that all across the country
at the national level we are trying to
provide that information about the
Wastewater testing sites on a website
but I know we can do more as we are
beginning to escalate the benefit of
this tool to actually try and provide
that in a more consistent basis to
everyone in all communities Wastewater
data right now covers about just over 60
percent of the population we're aiming
to do better to go with uh trying to get
to that 80 coverage
um and but when it's not the easiest
thing to interpret but I think you would
appreciate that wherever you're living
for example I'm in Ottawa our local
public health officer is communicating
these signals
um in a real-time basis to the
population so I still urge everyone to
listen to your local public health
authorities
thanks so much for that um switching
gear is just slightly several experts
we've spoken to say the approach to
prescribing Pax lovid has been a bit of
a patchwork Province to Province and
we're wondering if the public health
um public health of Canada intends to do
some kind of implementation study and
what you would hope to learn from
something like that
really great question so we have um
at the federal level of course
facilitated the purchasing of pax lovid
and distributed I think today 150
000 or thereabouts courses uh to the
province and territories they are trying
to figure out how to deploy because the
the drug has to be provided to high-risk
populations within five days of the
initial onsets of illness or symptoms or
test positivity
so I think my message to all Canadians
who may be in high risk such as the
immunocompromised
figure out in your community right now
how you can get access to that
medication should you need it because it
is a bit different across different
areas of Canada and including some
provinces enabling pharmacies to
prescribe and others are using a more
centralized distribution mechanism and
also using Physicians who normally look
after those at higher risk through those
networks to enable access but it is a
bit different across the the country and
but but I think as a personal protective
measure and getting prepared try and
figure this out now before you get ill I
think is really important but we are
actually
um
doing
um collaborating The Province and
territories but also researchers in
looking at the effectiveness of the Pax
lovid medication as an outpatient
measure because the health Canada
authorization and the clinical trials
were done in unvaccinated populations so
we want to know what additional benefit
the drug has for the vaccinated
population which is the majority in
Canada of course as well as providing
the drug to the unvaccinated population
who are at the highest risk
um the feasibility and the practicality
of operationalization of this deployment
is not simple but we are trying to study
it and see if we can translate best
practices across jurisdictions including
how do you enable Pharmacy pharmacists
to give out this drug so yes we are
going to be looking at the best
practices for deployment
LA Press
hi I was wondering how efficient is it
um
for provinces to recommend the use of uh
of wearing a mask as opposed to making
it mandatory
yes and thank you for that question we
are in a difficult period we call it the
transition period not only is the virus
trying to find its way
um in the world and transitioning and
we're transitioning from what I would
hope is the acute crisis phase but into
the sort of somewhat unknown uncertain
territory of viral Evolution we should
keep up with these layers of measures
um I think
um trying to continue to observe the
impacts of requirements versus
recommendations is very important
um I think for now everybody should be
layering on those protections on top of
the vaccines including the mask
it sometimes takes a guesswork out of
people I think on a practical basis if
there was a mandate but I think all
public health authorities at the moment
are trying to shift the Paradigm into
making sure people learn these good
habits and be able to employ them
but I think my message is also not just
protecting yourself but please try and
remember there are others in your
community who are more at high risk of
this virus and you wearing a mask or
getting vaccinated helps them
so I think that's a really important
message I don't know I think in
different communities depending on the
context the social cohesion and and
other variables each of those policies
might work better and there's a
different circumstances but I think
people are Keen to see and trust that
the population
are able to employ those layers of
protection
do you consider that we are now in a
sixth wave of covet across Canada and as
for the vaccination for the booster uh
for instance in Quebec only 53 percent
of the eligible population has received
it so far even though it's been
available since January
um so do you see that there's less of a
concern in the population about getting
the booster doses
yeah this is the the really important
question is the main message that I have
for everyone today which is to go get
boosted certainly for the 18 plus
because we are experiencing the upward
surge of uh cases right now I think it's
semantics as to whether you call it the
sixth wave or not but there's an
increase which is um being seen in most
areas across Canada some provinces
didn't really see much of a way for the
beginning of the pandemic and they and
they're experiencing the most important
uh Resurgence uh in in the last month
since Omicron this is a omicon wave we
believe is
really taken over by the ba2 sub lineage
which at the last analysis
um we are now at certainly over 60
percent uh or more of um the
identifications and the sequencing and
now ba2 which is even more transmissible
than ba1 so we are seeing that
Resurgence whether you call it the sixth
wave or however many wave there is in
your local jurisdiction uh it is a
Resurgence and that is why it's
important to get that booster now I
think that
um as the Omicron wave began to descend
um I think people uh felt that maybe
they don't need that booster and I think
we strongly recommended recommending
that right now some people also think
that well I just got an infection so
maybe I don't need a booster we are
recommending it uh Nasi the national
advisory committee on the United States
is still recommending that even if
you've been infected you should get a
booster but you don't really need to get
it until about three months out from
your documented infection so I think
some some of those factors may be
playing into why we are not getting the
level of boost that we're seeing I also
recognize that at the time of the
initial
um effort in doing the Boost campaign
um it was in a very difficult period of
time where vaccinators were getting
infected we had a um
absenteeism from the health public
health and health system so it's not
easy to increase access and making sure
vaccines are accessible to all
populations but I think I've seen local
public health right now trying to
mobilize clinics trying to get
um
Toronto for example deploying vaccines
in different spots in the city to try
and improve access to the booster so
that's always important I think in
upping air
booster rate so this is our I think
Collective effort right now
to get the boosters in
um as the wave is increasing
question Jamie maracher global
hi Dr Tam can you hear me okay
yes thank you okay
um my first question for you is what is
your recommendation as we head into
um the long weekend I know you know this
is our the third
um pandemic Easter that people have
celebrated last year the recommendation
was you know kind of stay separate if
you can do a virtual hosting what's the
official recommendation this year
yes and I think get your booster
um I hope you've already got it but this
can be
um a reminder
I think many of the religious uh
observations over the weekend
uh in any religion is promoting
compassion and protection of each other
and community
all of the religions promote that so I
think as part of that please go and get
uh up to date with your vaccination and
wear a mask
anywhere where you're going into an
enclosed environment with people who are
not in your household I do think that
people want to gather
um try and it make sure that you can
improve the ventilation as much as
possible or gather outside but you can
still celebrate and have opportunities
to do that in a safer way we we've all
learned those habits and behaviors and
but there is a risk so if you were at a
very high risk you know you may want to
layer on other protection measures like
getting a rapid test there should still
be rapid test available in the
communities I know that the federal
government has continuously deployed
these rapid tests
they have their limitations too but I
think they do help if you get a positive
test to stay home and not spread it to
other people so so I think with all
those measures try and celebrate in a
safer way as possible
thank you um and then my second question
to you is do you have any concerns about
um the new variants that we're seeing so
XE which we know is already here in
Canada and now ba4 and ba5 and have the
latter been detected in Canada do you
know yes it's very important through the
global genomic sequencing Network to
keep track of the variants
um I think all of the above that you've
just talked about be a four or five as a
ba3 of course
Omicron uh derived and some of the um
recombinants that starts with the X so
XE also a recombination of ba1 and ba2
the latter XE is a combination mostly of
the spike protein of the ba2 variant but
with genes from the A1 so so they're a
evolution of that Omicron Family Tree
and we we do expect that to happen
because there's a lot of transmission of
this virus all over the world
I think x e got some attention because
there's evidence of some Community
Transmission in some countries such as
the United Kingdom so we're watching
that one really carefully
um you mentioned that we had some
detections
um we some of those sequencing are not
always easy to decipher or classify so
so that is a shifting landscape but we
may have a few but
um I think my the national microbiology
lab is saying that we in fact probably
none of them truly fit the XE sequence
definitions so we will revise that as we
get more information but all to say is
that we're watching out for those signs
of whether these variants are more
transmissible but in particular whether
there's any shift in the severity of the
impact of those variants at the moment
we have not detected any ba4 or five in
Canada
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
civil prevalence
um the the there's anti-cordano
popularity
um with the number of antibodies
um
which is accelerating and the ultra
another
but it's evident that there is an
increase
modeling
um
assay
um Effie casca Avon is meh effective
but generally speaking modeling
um how do you say forecast
um in
umization center and we are seeing the
hospitalizations
um going up in some jurisdictions
um ICU admissions haven't really seen
much of an uptake right now we hope
that's the impact of the vaccinations so
that's another reason uh that we're
promoting the booster that those that
have health at Thai sample
booster doses
big Urban centers but should it be done
elsewhere as well low
um
that is being used it's very important
little easy
um
please the swazo
yeah uh more than 60 of the population
of testing
so the ways water surveillance is being
done right now that covers about 60 of
the population including some in the
north that has been utilized very
effectively like the Northwest
Territories
so I think we're trying to continue to
expand that that 60 to 80 is not always
easy those tend to be communities that
are smaller but I think we will keep
working at that and in support of the
different networks but I think what is
important as some of the journalists
have pointed out today is trying to make
that data more evident more available to
the population and that complements I
think the PCR testing and and other
aspects of surveillance
this question next question Dylan
Robertson Winnipeg Free Press
hi Dr Tam thanks for taking our
questions
um I was wondering about uh if there was
ever an attempt to register rather sorry
rapid test data among the medical
officers of held uh we know that the
Northwest Territories asks its citizens
to report the results of Rapid tests and
I'm just wondering if there's ever a
discussion at the table of chief medical
officers uh to have other jurisdictions
do this or to set up any kind of a
federal federal program like that
yeah I think we have discussed this and
and sharing some experiences and best
practices so I think
um jurisdictions are continuing to
examine that as another potential uh
surveillance vehicle
um so I think we are certainly
interested in Innovations in that space
PCR continues to be important so even
with
um a drop in testing
um and because it's more targeted
towards the higher-risk population we do
need to have more representative testing
wherever possible so I think that should
continues to be encouraged
um I I am seeing some increase in PCR
testing
um just in the last week or so
um probably as as the curve of the
Omicron variant is is on the upward
trajectory but we are doing enough for
us to perceive at the national and maybe
at the the provincial level the
trajectory uh the the shape of that
curve
um so that's that's still important
um I think the Wastewater is a very
um interesting Innovative and important
tool because it is going to be more
representative it doesn't matter who is
living in that community in those
communities but we will get a better
idea so I think local authorities are
just beginning to get used to how to
interpret how to communicate that data
so I I do think that is
um uh you know even worth even more of
an effort than trying to capture
individualized uh rapid test results and
people would do more than one and you
know how do you capture all of those
tests is sometimes difficult to work out
but that doesn't mean we shouldn't try
and have a go and see what Innovation
and what best practices can be shared so
I will certainly continue to do that
with my colleagues at the special
advisory committee
thank you and uh could you please expand
on your point about social cohesion when
it comes to masked mandates versus
some suggestions because you mentioned
this plays out differently in different
contexts you'd mentioned social cohesion
I'm just trying to wrap my head around
um like if you might have an example or
if you could just expand on that
well I think
um first of all I want to thank
um everyone living in Canada because it
is with Collective
uh Community Spirit and the spirit of
not just protecting ourselves but
protecting others that we've done I
think actually relatively well we always
do better
um in Canada we could have not have done
this without
um the community coming together and I
think that's an important aspect of how
you do Public Health policies going
forwards and I think giving people the
data and the information
to uh add the layers of protection is
important right now I think everybody
should think about uh getting the
booster and the masking and improving
ventilation for themselves and for
others so that's what I think I mean by
social cohesion I don't think it's
um necessary helpful helpful to be
divisive in our
um this discourse I think everybody
um
first to be heard
um but I think from a public health
perspective it is clear that you know
vaccines are effective you should get
boosted you should wear a mask
um so as much as possible
people should do that
um one one aspect of social cohesion is
that it's quite difficult for the public
right now uh because I think people at
least I've heard anecdotally people wear
masks
when it's you know the your local
jurisdiction doesn't require you're
wearing a mask and people are giving you
comments that's not appropriate
we need to support people in being able
to do that if they want to and I think
that's one aspect that we need to work
together on
um there's probably some very good
reasons why someone wear a mask even if
others don't so support them in doing so
Canada
19 activity everywhere
um dunk
is that right it's true
um
what's going on with uh covid-19 in
their uh
um
yeah
um please and in addition Jam radio wax
Sam please
is very important
so it doesn't matter maybe which
jurisdiction you're in
or whether it's mandated or not it's
just a really important thing to do and
dunk
and get the booster dose
access to a PCR test
um
we'll see our tests um video
for individuals please
um
but
um
the test
[Applause]
and the testing tests that are in the
testing next question is
hi Dr Tim it's uh Rachel Haynes from TTV
can you hear me okay I can perfect thank
you so much um I wanted to ask you uh
very similar questions to what some of
my colleagues have been asking about
provinces and
um if they should be issuing mask
mandates or issuing recommendations and
I just wanted to ask you and hope that
you could answer directly of if
provinces could have dropped them
mandate should bring it back
well it's up to them obviously and the
point I was trying to make is my mask
anyways whether the province is is local
jurisdictions recommending it or not
when the cases are rising and activities
rising in your in your community I think
in general in Canada right now all over
the place there's RS activities so it's
actually the risk assessment is
relatively simple at this point in time
um provinces know that population are
better than I do as to whether it
actually is more effective
um to use a mandate or not sometimes it
makes things easier for people takes
their guesswork out of
um the need for different settings to
figure things out but I think just as a
general rule of thumb wearing a mask is
important right now
thank you and my next question is about
vaccine passports and some of the
vaccine passports that still exist like
the federal vaccine passport for travel
on planes and trains require that
everybody needs two shots right now but
given what you're saying about the
waning efficacy and your push for
boosters today would you like to see the
definition of fully vaccinated changed
so it requires everyone to have at least
three shots
well I think the message today is get up
to date with your vaccination which
includes a booster for the eligible
population to all extent of purposes
that's 18 plus and also can be offered
to adolescents so that is the most
important message I think the uh and we
want everybody to have had the
opportunity to have had that third dose
to be boosted and um and some people who
just got infected may need to wait
another three months
so um I think the discussions on whether
the definition of up-to-date should be
included in a vaccine
passes is an ongoing discussion but
right now we just want to make sure
everyone has the opportunity and the
access to that important booster dose
next question is for palak manga
doctor time can you hear me okay
yes I can thank you thanks for taking
our questions
um I just wanted to follow up but also
uh from some of my earlier colleagues
around Pax lovid usage and uptake
um it seems like the bottom line is
provinces don't seem to be using the
supply that they got from the feds at
least at the rate that some experts want
to see so far you did mention that we're
seeing a greater severity and from what
I recall we hope that Peck slope would
kind of help curb that can you speak to
what might be hindering the
um I don't know if it's uptake or
distribution to make it more widely
available on the ground and essentially
what role maybe that five day period
might be playing or might not be playing
and just what you're hearing from
perfect colleagues on this
yes um so just to clarify your first um
Point
um is that yes we are seeing in a uh you
know the the uptick in hospitalizations
although not yet in Ico emissions we
hope that will stay down
and so Pax lovit is given to individuals
at higher risk of severe outcomes when
they just at the beginning of their
illness when their symptoms are still
mild and that's the time to take it
because you gotta get the the medication
in which cuts down on the viral
replication and and and how it can
um multiply in your body so you got to
get that medication pretty fast
so that is a challenge
and that is a challenge for example when
we are using influenza antivirals is you
you have to get
um those antivirals provided at the
earlier part of the illness sometimes
people don't even know they're sick they
think they have allergies because it's
spring but if you're at a high risk
be hyper Vigilant that any symptoms
could be covered and also if you've been
in contact with anyone else who has
covid think of the possibility that you
may have it
um at that point
um you know I I am suggesting that
people actually find out
in your local community how you access
paxilovid because it could be different
in different areas and you should know
this ahead of time so that you can get
into that window of opportunity then you
need a test it can be rapid tests it can
be PCR but you need a test to figure out
you have covet before you're given that
tax lobid so the testing and the
medication has to be linked uh in a very
efficient way so I think that's what
jurisdictions uh making sure that those
pathways are clarified and they're
trying all different methods to try and
make this work
um so yes I think all of us would like
to see Pax loaded being mobilized
um more widely now that we have a
significant amount of drug so I I think
it's multiple factors one is the public
and those that hire is knowing that such
a drug exists so so hopefully all of you
can disseminate that message
have them get prepared by finding out
how to access that in your local
vicinity and talk to your doctor because
those at high risk generally have
someone looking after them who can help
them access it and at the same time as
Province and territories and she's
trying to figure out the most efficient
way to roll it out
but I think we need to keep at it
because we will be using these kind of
medications
um in a more significant way as we have
more access to antivirals in the future
which is great news we just need to know
how to get it out to people fast
yeah thank you and I guess just to
follow up it you know at the same time
we're also seeing that that some at-risk
people are waiting for the treatment
um and I know that you you're sort of
highlighting my
as a time crunch here uh you did also
mention that we're expecting a
Resurgence in the fall and that
researchers are right now looking at the
best practices for for the deployment of
this
how soon can some of these best
practices for this treatment be I guess
identified and followed given we do have
that that sort of five-day window and
essentially what guarantees can you
provide that there are provincial sorry
that that the provincial authorities
will follow those best practices or will
it merely be optional advice
or guidance well I think sharing best
practice is very important which is
taking place with the achievement
officers so I think in the next days
you'll you'll hear about
um how provinces are expanding access
Quebec for example is trying to enable
pharmacists so in their context they've
worked out how to do that with their
regulatory bodies of the medical
professional colleges this is medical
practice so how do you enable that to
happen and enable pharmacists to be able
to prescribe and what are the supports
to the pharmacists should they uh be
doing that and so all of that has been
worked out in one jurisdiction so that
same kind of practice could be looked at
by others but the distribution mechanism
could be different in a smaller
Community compared to a big city as well
so we we will continue to share best
practices but I I hope that what you
will see in the next little while well
our jurisdictions are able to
communicate how they're doing that
they're working really hard I know that
but we also need the public to be aware
that the drug exists
next question is from David thurton
hi Dr Tam what can you tell us about the
uptake for novavax and how popular has
this alternative been so far and was
buying J J
a success in your point of view or a
failure
so um first of
first of all and we are
really fortunate in Canada to have
access to the best vaccines but also a
range of them because of the Investments
we made at the beginning of the pandemic
you you cannot tell at the beginning of
this pandemic how the vaccines are going
to be
um you know developed or how effective
they're going to be
so we happen to have access to the best
vaccines that we know
and also now have a choice for people
should they not take the MRI and vaccine
for whatever reason even though they are
you know the benefits outweigh the risk
we just keep trying to communicate that
and there's very good evidence that they
work so but the jnj and the AstraZeneca
and other vaccines have been provided
just so that we can cover off anyone who
isn't taking the MRA vaccine
um so investments in biomedical
technology always carries a certain
amount of risk and that should be known
to everyone and you just don't know
um and so I I think we will continue to
pursue the other Technologies as well as
you know there are other ones are still
up and coming in the pipeline
and the reason is that even if they're
not
um use now what about into the future
what about in Winter waves how do you
know what what happens when you boost
with those vaccines on top of the MRI
vaccine all of those are very relevant
um Technical and medical
um questions that still need to be asked
the uptake of the Nova vaccine I can't
give you an update at the moment I think
uh those are just uh beginning to be
rolled out so
um I think if you get back to our
Communications colleagues we'll give you
an update when we have those numbers
okay I appreciate you saying when you
don't know and answer your question uh
that's always great well not great to
hear but you know it's better than not
answering the question okay
um so but to that question though like
is there any information though about
the J J vaccine in particular do you
have a sense of whether
you know it has converted any vaccine or
holdouts if there haven't been any
success stories or has it kind of just
remained on the shelf and there's
nothing really to to speak of in terms
of converting people who were vaccine
hesitant and also in your point of view
like do you think we need a specific
Omicron
vaccine a vaccine to deal that's made
specifically to deal with autocrod and
it's very subvariate
um
so the J J again I think um I will have
to check into how many doses were given
out but we should actually have that
information but it will be a small
number but every every individual who's
vaccinated counts and I thank those who
access the J J vaccine but please do get
your booster and we recommend an MRI
boost because that has been proven to be
the most effective
approach and you can give that makes
schedule so if you had J J you can get
that mRNA vaccine boost and we have
billions of doses of vaccine being
provided in the world that has
demonstrated the safety profile of these
vaccines
um so so I think that that number I
think can be provided but I I think it
would be a small number
um and in terms of omicron's specific
strain right now all of the vaccines of
course uh deployed across the world and
certainly in Canada focus on the
ancestral strain
and vaccine manufacturers are
um right now testing the a uh the
vaccine strain against the omicon
variant so I hope to see some of those
results
um in the next months
as to whether the results will be
um in time
four by four for example only time will
tell but they do have to be completed
fairly quickly and with of course good
results
for them to be deployed in in that kind
of time frame
I do think it's important to have a
range of vaccine strains I think that
just keep boosting with the current
strain is an interim likely to be an
interim measure but I have to reiterate
three dose is important even a fourth
though for the highest risk and so far
but this is the goodness so far for
every variant from alpha to Omicron
the vaccines have performed well against
serious outcomes so that's just
something to remember
maybe we don't need to change it but I I
suspect that the trajectory forward is
one where we do have to update our
vaccine strains
so I don't see any other raised hand but
we have still five minutes so we might
have time for one last question so
raise your hand if you have a question
okay so Dylan Robertson go ahead
uh hi Dr Tam I'm just looking back on
the part about social cohesion because I
I don't quite understand I mean you're
telling people to not harass people who
choose to wear a mask at the same time
you're saying that it provides um you
know less guesswork if the provinces
tell people to just wear a mask you know
plus people you know who have to justify
it because
as they can say look I'm forced to look
I'm just trying to understand the social
cohesion and and the downside I'm not
advocating for a position but I'm just
trying to understand what the medical
officers of Health are thinking here in
saying that you know if we make this
optional it's better for social cohesion
when we have people with disabilities
saying they can't protect themselves
anymore
well I think as as I've been trying to
explain this is a period of transition
it's not going to be easy so that's the
first thing to acknowledge
um different communities not just at the
provincial level but the local level
know the community the most and what can
continuously to bring people in a
cohesive way instead of a divisive way
wearing a mask
and doing all the other things that
protect each other is what we're trying
to promote
if they see in the epidemiology or with
a variant that's really severe
and highly transmissible
other public health measures may have to
come back into play
so they there is a balance and they are
trying to make that balance it's not
going to be that easy and they will
observe what happens
as the policy has shifted
if necessary I'm sure they will think
about re-implementing measures but that
is up to them
I think at this moment in time is very
important for us not to divide the
population and and keep messaging the
need to protect each other and and so I
think that's the most important thing
um
I'm not sure that's a satisfactory
answer to your question but um I think
that's what we're trying to say is that
we can't have too many of the them and
us is about working together and yes we
need to advocate for those who are at
the highest risk
so so that others
um who are listening right now
um or come together and protect each
other and that's the right thing to do
okay so I think this is all the time we
have
so thank you Dr Tam for your time for
your time and uh thanks everyone
thank you everyone have a safe weekend
bye-bye